je me suis senti vraiment trahi je t'ai
complètement dénigrer quoi
[Musique]
je suis black listé dans tous les
établissements la boîte d'intérim qui
m'envoyaient des missions tous les jours
ne m'a plus envoyé aucune mission depuis
ce lundi 24 septembre
[Musique]
et là l'hôpital pour lequel j'avais
signé un cdi au 1er septembre
me contacter le lendemain de l'émission
pour m'annoncer qu'on matin le lundi
pour mettre fin à la période d'essai on
me le dit pas clairement mais c'est
comme ça que je ressens je vais à cet
entretien la et le cadre de santé me
reçoit très peinés et il me dit et là on
va mettre fin à la période d'essai même
si elle n'est pas terminée
je lui dis qu'est ce qui se passe je
tombe des nues je sais pas pourquoi il
met fin à la période d'essai dites-moi
est-ce que j'ai fait une faute
si vous saviez que vous allez mettre fin
à la période d'essai pourquoi
m'avez-vous laisser travailler le samedi
et le dimanche
et là il me répond pas je lui qui m'a
alors c'est à cause de l'émission dites
moi que c'est à cause de l'émission
envoyé spécial
ils menacent les épaules comme ça il me
dit et là je suis désolé c'est pas moi
qui ai pris la décision on n'a pas à se
justifier on doit pas vous donner de
motif étant donné que vous êtes en
période d'essai dans les heures qui
suivent je reçois un appel d'une boîte
d'intérim qui nous contactent
régulièrement voir tous les jours pour
le proposer quatre missions de nuit on
s'équipe chiffrés qui devait commencer
donc ce soir là le lundi 24 mois je les
accepte volontiers je me dis et là tu
vas pas te laisser abattre
alors j'y vais bien entendu à l'avance
au bout de 25 minutes la iv sort en
panique me disant ah excusez moi je suis
vraiment désolé la rue a pris du retard
j'en ai pour cinq minutes et on va
visiter l'établissement et là elle
ressort 30 secondes plus tard le regarde
elle reprend dans la pièce et n'est plus
jamais ressortie j'ai la boîte d'intérim
qui m'appellent et qui me dit et là je
suis désolé on va lui les quatre
missions rentrez chez vous on vous paye
trois heures pour le déplacement jeu je
craque en fait je pleure parce que
c'était trop pour moi j'avais bossé
toute la nuit dernière le matin
j'apprenais que j'étais licencié de
l'hôpital le soir même je suis viré de
l'établissement pour lequel je dois
aller travailler comme une malpropre
quelque part et
c'est lourd passé beaucoup ça fait
beaucoup parce que parce que je fais
juste notre devoir de citoyenne je
dénonce simplement des faits qui sont
réelles
aujourd'hui c'est pas possible d'être
deux aides soignantes prenent
établissement qui accueille 94 saisis
dans la nuit
c'est juste pas possible on n'a que deux
bras deux jambes on peut pas être
partout à la fois c'est des personnes
qui sont âgés qu'ils ont besoin
d'attention et les traiter comme ça on
doit les accompagner dignement vers une
fin de vie correcte aujourd'hui les
traiter comme on les traite aujourd'hui
c'est juste inadmissible on peut pas se
permettre de dire si elle a fait pipi et
que j'ai plus de couches
on la laisse dans sa couche plainte du
riz c'est horrible on demande une couche
supplémentaire alors mais vous avez
dépassé le quota on va vous en donner
aujourd'hui on en est arrivé à un point
où ces entreprises
ces grands groupes il calcule même le
grammage alimentaire pour les résidents
c'est 50 grammes pour l'entrée 100
grammes pour le plat au goûter c'est une
malle de l'aisne un sirop de fraise et
quand tu y as du cerveau parce que
parfois c'est de l'eau c'est des
personnes qui sont abandonnés dans sa
maison de retraite
il faut pas oublier que nos jeunes
aujourd'hui c'est les vieux de demain
j'arrête pas de le dire mais il faut
vraiment que qu'on prenne conscience que
ça pourrait être un grand parent nos
parents et nous mêmes dans quelques
années qu'il faut pas qu'on la sait un
modèle de société comme celui ci pour
nos enfants parce que on court vers la
catastrophe